for me I can't wait for Tarantino to do
a crowdfunding campaign i can't wait for
George Clooney to do a crowdfunding
campaign it's like you know those people
should be doing you know I want Turkey
know the finances next film you know
through a crowd fund campaign why not
you know and I think he would do he
potentially could do some really
interesting things that and he has an
audience base that will do it that will
engage with him and you know and I think
you're going to start I hope you start
saying bigger and bigger filmmakers and
personalities start to do it and then
part of that is not just that people get
used to Kickstarter but in terms of
giving over money but that they get used
to the kinds of experiences that they
can expect or can engage with through
Kickstarter and then that opens up their
possibilities in a sense they're their
minds as audience members as to what's
possible and then hopefully that will
then encourage other filmmakers to do or
other artists to do some more kinds of
things which just expands the
possibilities you know for me it's
important at this time to think about
expansion as opposed to contraction you
know and for people to complain about
Zach Braff it's about contraction you
know let's keep this little thing for
our club you know and to me that never
works you know and because then that's
the big that's the death of a culture in
a sense when you try to keep it only for
the select few you know I'm not saying
that you want to purposefully promote it
to the mass but if you try to constrict
it that I think causes issues and to be
honest it's not about what are we
looking at it's about finance you know
and it's finance really you know ever
anything about some select club I mean
you know I think that those people who
complain about Zach Braff should be more
concerned with making better art
you